I definitely forgot that she snorted I
was like oh that was 12 years old I met
her we talked for maybe 2 or 3 hours or
am when he asked me to be his girlfriend
I used to get off at 140 and go visit
her at school I thought I was a big nerd
he seemed like a really cool skater boy
it was Danny's first kiss we went under
the hair hockey table and it happened I
felt great I really liked Danny
the puppy love kind of thing Danny and I
broke up because he liked another girl
and I could tell I feel bad about the
break-up because a week after I broke up
I got with my next girlfriend I guess
today I'm pretty nervous but I also
think it's just a kiss
reenacting the first kiss that's really
ready right oh oh you got it - Meghan
you fit me - good what is this
tattoo every can I take off my glasses
why were we underneath it talk to the
table I don't know do they know you went
under first probably I have no idea we
did everything
what's up Lana's got a kiss - anything I
know
got me a dollar you look scared don't
look scared way to sound wise I don't
know
this matter how you did it Tim really
did me good thank you
there we did it we're good it was just a
kid right yeah I know yeah what yeah
this is just the kid pills
once last time you saw me like two years
ago no but he can I said you were cool I
forgot you're also shy hang on again
ever
yeah yeah it's not weird you know yeah
all right she's always been like a
goofball feeling old jokes pop up in my
head just by seeing him that was like
the most fun part I guess we've kind of
grown with each other yeah I miss daddy
like too much in a couple ways mister as
a friend yeah she was cool every time we
meet up it's kind of like I saw her
yesterday or something it did feel a lot
like a best friendship I think that kind
of has followed me in relationships I've
had since being younger maybe Danny
started that a little bit it was cool it
was fun I'd do it again